hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
antisthenes was one of the students
and friends of socrates the philosopher
from athens who we know so much about
because of plato
and xenophon antisthenes himself
although he
wrote a lot of books none of them have
survived and what we know
of him comes to us largely through
people like diogenes laertes or xenophon
and diogenes laertes
credits antisthenes with being the
founder of the school of cynicism the
the school you could say of the
hound or the dog and there's a bit of
discussion
and and disagreement in the scholarship
in the present day about whether
diogenes
who is reputed to have been antisthenes
student
is really the founder of cynicism or
whether antisthenes
was the founder we're just going to go
with this notion that antisthenes
derives a certain way of living from
socrates
inaugurates this school and that
diogenes was
his student more famous than him in some
respects
and that's you know one narrative that
we can go with in part because
there's you know there are reasons that
are given against
uh that narrative but the the reasons i
don't think
support diogenes being the originator
any more than they do
anticipating so we're just going to go
with diogenes
narrative here he is a student of
socrates and like most of the students
of socrates
he focused on certain aspects of what it
was that this figure
taught and so diogenes tells us
that he learned endurance this is an
important term criteria
from socrates and also disregard
of feeling apartheids or apothea
the capacity not to be affected
by one's feelings one's desires and
aversions the the whole range of
affectivity
having a capacity to control yourself
and another term that gets used uh
that's very important
for socrates and also important for
antisthenes
is temperance or self-control sofrosune
right
so all of this involves a capacity to
resist
the appetites a capacity to
make ourselves feel less of the things
that we shouldn't feel
that doesn't mean that we don't feel
anything another
important thing that gets talked about
here before we get into the discussion
of
wisdom and virtue specifically
is this interesting you know question
that gets asked
what good is philosophy and here we have
to depart from you know what we
might think of as academic philosophy
we'll get to that in
a moment this is philosophy as it's
lived
and antisthenes says it's the ability to
hold converse with myself to be able to
have an interior dialogue to be
able to be on my own and not
craving for stimulation
or conversation with other people
now that said diogenes also reports and
i think this is corroborated
by what we see of antisthenes for
example
in xenophon that he is
um yeah here we go the ability to
converse with myself
he was able to talk with
people you know very easily here we go
of all the socratic's antisthenes alone
is praised by theo pompous so there were
writings about him that we've lost
who says he had consummate skill and
could by means of an agreeable discourse
win over
whomsoever he pleased and then he refers
to xenophon's
uh banquet or symposium
and so that's quite interesting isn't it
that
this guy he could be on his own
totally on his own and be cool with that
and yet if he was engaging with other
people
he would be able to converse with them
and even bring them to
another way of living or at least
reconsidering things in that he's very
much like socrates
thing that uh that diogenes liertes
tells us about and this is sort of a
legacy thing
which is quite interesting is that he
and hispanies leads to the
um and there's different ways of
translating this the the text that i
have here
the indifference but it could also be
translated
as not being easily moved apathea
of diogenes right the encretia the
continents it's translated
self-control is another great way to
translate it being able to
resist uh things endurance is another
way of krates
and then the carteria you know
translated
as hearty hood but also could be
translated as endurance
and it's interesting because if we look
at aristotle and i think this this
reflects
not just aristotle's own doctrine but a
division that's being made
encaratea means not being mastered by
pleasures
and carteria means not being mastered by
pains
so they're two sides of the same thing
and
antis way of life and the cynic
approach that he's taking whether it's
called cynicism at the time or not
is held to lead to these good
qualities so let's talk about virtue
itself arete
excellence this is something that the
ancient greeks were very focused on it
plays a major role
in their ethics so there's a lot of
things that
um diogenes layer taste tells us that
antisthenes
said about virtue one of the most
important ones is that it is sufficient
for happiness so this is this is an idea
that the cynics have
the stoics later you know founded by
zeno are going to have this
as well and he says also that nobility
or
you know being a genuinely good person
belongs to none other than the virtuous
so
this is a radical doctrine he also says
that virtue can be taught
which is very important because
otherwise we wouldn't be able to
enjoy the happiness we would like to
have
if it's sufficient for happiness but you
can't teach it then you're
you either have to find it or not the
fact that it can be taught
is is very important a little bit later
he also calls it a
weapon that cannot be taken away now
what does that mean
so unlike so many other things that we
might have that we could consider to be
good things
virtue can't be taken away the only one
that can cause you to lose virtue
when you have it is you deciding to
throw it away
for other things like physical pleasures
or not feeling pain or having lots of
money
or fame or following the social rules
you know following the law
of custom and habit that he's going to
refer to
a little bit later you know meeting
social expectations all of those things
you can you can have those but those can
be taken away whereas virtue
you have that it's something that you've
acquired
a little bit later he also says virtue
is a matter of
actions erga deeds the things that you
actually do and it doesn't require
words logoi or learning and the word
there
is the word that we use for study or for
for being a pupil of somebody
that doesn't mean that words and
learning don't play any role
as we're going to see he actually
advocates laying up a store of them in a
certain way
but it also means that the stress has to
be laid on what you actually
do there's a great story in here
about one of the things that he does
so he says antisthenes is held
responsible for the exile
of anatus and the execution of melatus
now who are these people these are the
people who brought the charges against
socrates
and got him killed so of all of the
students of socrates you know
antisthenes is the one who gets things
done
you know he gets uh anatus exiled by
running into a bunch of other guys who
are there to study with socrates he's
like well
you could study with him but that guy
over there got him killed so
they drive him out and melatus is
actually
executed so you know that's uh
you could say a matter of justice um
another thing that he stresses that we
see going through
sometimes into the stoic school in in
authors like masonis rufus for example
is that virtue is the same for women
as it is for men this appears to have
been a genuinely socratic teaching
as we see reflected for example in the
meno
or in the republic very clearly
and antis seems to have taken that to
heart himself so that's that's a very
important point
when we move on to talking about wisdom
and we're going to come back to virtue
in a moment wisdom
is very closely connected with virtue
for him he says the wise person
is going to be guided by the laws of
virtue what it is that
virtue demands or requires of us
not the laws that were accustomed to
within the city and this is very typical
of the
cynic viewpoint this is one reason why
you know if this is correct he would be
a founder of cynicism the cynic said
social conventions are not as important
as following
our actual nature and our nature is to
be
beings that can cultivate virtue
a little bit later and this goes to the
question of
whether we need words or learning he's
going to say
wisdom is a is a most secure stronghold
or set of walls
which never crumbles away nor is
betrayed walls of defense must be
constructed in our own
impregnable that is undefeatable
reasonings and here he uses logis
moist right so you know logos is words
or discourses logis moist
that means something that's kind of
structured things that we could
think about and we know that anticipates
actually wrote books so presumably
a lot of this was in the books that have
long that have been lost
since then but the notion is that by
living a certain life by learning things
about the world learning things about
ourselves making certain
proper decisions we establish a set of
you know fortifications within ourselves
another thing that he says is really
quite interesting
nothing is foreign or impracticable
and we'll talk about what those words
mean for the wise person
now a little we have to modify that
because a little bit later
uh diagnotists says that
good actions are fair even actual even
evil actions foul count all wickedness
as
foreign or alien and that's just
actually translating the same two words
ceno or xenos right so
if it's good stuff or in different
things
nothing is foreign to the wise person
the cynic stressed cosmopolitanism being
a member of the
cosmos rather than just being a citizen
of a particular city
and this is reflective of it
impracticable
unable to be done finding yourself in
sort of you might say an
end a dead end where you can't proceed
for the wise person anything that they
want to set their mind to they can find
a poros away
so they're not aporon they're not a you
know is stuck in
opporia where they can't do anything and
this is a little bit different than
you know what we see in the operatic
dialogues
in plato or socrates you know says wow
we just don't know how to proceed
he also talks about love and friendship
and this is again a very radical
doctrine
you know those who we feel erotic desire
towards
and get into relationships with we can
we can
pursue what the flesh needs very easily
antisthene says
we'll put that aside but when it comes
to feeling of
affection you know loving somebody in
the other sense
who should we love we should love the
good
even if you know our family are close to
us
if they're not good people we we really
should transfer that feeling of love
to other people he says
this person will not disdain to love
only the wise person knows who are
worthy to be loved so wisdom helps us
with that
he tells us esteem and honest person
you know a good person over a kinsmen
be with a handful of good men fighting
against all the bad then the hosts of
bad men
against a handful of good men he says
even enemies can be helpful pay
attention to your enemies
because they reveal to you your faults
which then you can work on
to become more virtuous and wise even
your enemies don't
intend anything good for you but they
can be turned to good
so this is uh you know what we've got in
diogenes lierte
of antisthenes teachings
and sayings and way of life this would
be a very
early example of the cynic school if
indeed antisthenes is the founder of the
cynics school
and all of this is very consistent with
what it is that later cynics at least
the good ones
are preaching and practicing
you